Prince Harry and his wife Megan arrived
on the island of Fiji today on the
eighth day of their South Pacific tour
despite wet weather the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex received a warm welcome during
a traditional ceremony this morning
their visit echos another royal visit
1953 by harry's grandparents Ben
Elizabeth and Prince Phillip Jonathan
Vigliotti is following the royal couple
in Suva Fiji Prince Harry and Megan
arrived in Fiji to a royal welcome first
greeted by a guard of honor at Nassau
Airport before heading to a packed
Albert Park where they were presented
with a whale's tooth and the ceremonial
drink kava
[Applause]
but the highlight came later as members
of Fiji's Niccolo village performed
their warrior dance this traditional
dance known as the mecca has been passed
down through generations in fact this
entire ceremony is identical to what
held in this very location 65 years ago
[Music]
the program in Albert Park was wound up
by warriors performing the clubs and
spear dances all most fearsome reminders
of their warlike past the year was 1953
when Queen Elizabeth and Prince Philip
arrived on the island as part of their
first Commonwealth tour Her Majesty was
looking her radiant best on this South
Pacific Island the Queen's popularity
forged decades ago has been passed down
to her next generation for CBS this
morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Suva Fiji I tell you
what the past is a nice job of lining up
those historical shots with the
modern-day shots to sort of draw some
wonder wonder where that little girl who
treated Queen Elizabeth is now right he
left us there but he should track her
down I love looking at the historical
pictures you know today it was a
tradition really matters